let's go
get your ass out here boy you hold up
the show
don't make me come down there i'll thump
your skull for you
damn it do friend you're putting me
behind i gotta schedule the cape
you better be sick or dead in there i
[ __ ] you not
you hear me
oh my holy god
[Music]
i want every man on this cell block
question
start with that friend of his him
open 237
[Music]
what do you mean he just wasn't here
don't say that to me hey
don't say that to me again but sir he
wasn't i can see that hey
think i'm blind is that what you're
saying
am i blind hey no sir
what about you you blind
tell me what this is last night's camp
you see dufresne's name there
i sure do see right there dufresne
he was in his cell it lights out stands
the reason he'd still be here in the
morning
i want him found not tomorrow not after
breakfast
now yes sir
let's go let's go move your butt
stand well
well what i see you two all the time
you're thick as thieves you are
he must have said something also
not a word
lord it's a miracle
man up and vanished like a fart in the
wind
nothing left but some damn rocks on the
windowsill
and that cupcake on the wall let's ask
her
maybe she knows what's saying there
fuzzy britches feel like talking
ah guess not why should she be any
different
this is a conspiracy that's what this
is one big
damn conspiracy and everyone's in on it
including here
[Music]
you